[Applause]
they say play on length of the court
and that's a foul oh whoa whoa
that should be a fight oh look out that
was og
and that is a wrestling move taking down
schroeder schroeder
schroeder was holding him up and i don't
know what he was thinking he actually
almost
ended up body slamming shooter
the officials will look at this if they
review this
uh i'm very interested to see what the
outcome will be
and restoring order as both benches
spill on to the court
i mean schroeder does a good job of
preventing the layup
but just and holding him he's holding
him right there so he doesn't fall
now he gets up and like yeah that's just
ridiculous
and look at trez coming in trez is
coming in there gary trent was in the
middle of it too
yeah but the third man in usually is the
guy that gets penalized the most so
we'll see who they rule as the third man
in is that going to be tres
or is it going to be gary dreams player
altercation
foul on the shoulder plays under further
review
all right they're going to take a look
at this and there's a lot to unpack here
with this replay and what just went down
between
ananobe and schroeder tennis hot and
there's gary trent
looked at the time is always trying to
break up but then tres came in of course
to
protect his guy
[Applause]
and look at markieff you know he's